Stefan will have the final
we'll just say a few words before before
he speaks as I predicted at beginning we
did sadly here terrible tales of events
around the world but i think the clear
shift between the meeting last year in
london and the meeting this year is that
there's more good news there's more good
work more good practice that has been
seen around the world and more is being
done but clearly we will suffer in the
future there will be more threats to our
cultural heritage especially it appears
if Corrin Venegas remains in position
from what she was telling us she's she's
bringing bringing bad luck and disaster
to us which I hopes not the case mamoun
Abdul Kareem said we will not lose this
battle brave and inspirational words but
he won't do it alone and we won't
succeed alone either I think it's really
important that we engage with a larger
group that we engage with others
involved in efforts in in countries of
trouble that we work with those
providing humanitarian aid we work with
businesses operating in the countries we
work with charities the military
Interpol and I shall say controversially
the antiquities trade as well I think it
is quite remiss to discuss legislation
against the antiquities trade without
them being present without them having a
say and in some occasions even saying we
can't provide the evidence but we want
to legislate legislation must be fair
and just and be seen to be accepted in
market countries I think it's absolutely
essential that we engage with a much
more diverse audience and I think also
as well restitution is a difficult issue
one which as was mentioned earlier is
maybe not the primary aim the primary
aim has to surely be prevention and
helping those working on the front line
to stop the terrible offenses that are
being committed so today has been a
great first step second step sorry from
the culture and crisis but i think that
there's further steps required will be
convenient
number of meetings over the summer to
discuss our convention idea and to
progress that looking in particular
workshops to discuss the technical and
legal aspects and commercial aspects of
of that proposal but if you agree as
well I think a third meeting in London
next year would maybe be a good step but
I have not discussed this with Stefan
yet but I'm hoping that our partnership
will continue and with the support of
Madame book cover as well and the with
UNESCO then we could look to do a third
meeting at that time I I will conclude
very quickly now just by asking you all
to join me in thanking Stefan for
pulling together today's conference the
handover
I think we have like seven minutes to
clear this space so I am really getting
to the end as well and I'm not wanting
to repeat all the very interesting
things which have been said this morning
this two-door is all around the world
showing us that this distraction is not
only a problem and a large issue in the
Middle East but but it reaches our heart
here in the United States as well in the
southwest with our Native American sites
and in Europe and and so many of you
have shown that I want to start with two
things about illicit traffic because you
know that's close to my heart since many
years the one thing which refers to what
Vernon said about villain from border
who was once the director-general of the
berlin museum where I used to work he
might have said that the smallest
fragment is like more important than the
largest cast but he bought in 1909 flora
by allegedly Leonardo da Vinci for
185,000 got marks from actually
unfortunately London forges who I mean
that was within from Boden right so and
the other note to use of was man about
binene as a scientist because yes i have
been a conservation scientist I'm just a
chemist I have had the opportunity to
work on more than 500 branches from
Benin and investigate them on their
authenticity and I can say there is a
common trend between all of that those
bronzes which are in private hands in
the hands of private collectors and
mostly fakes or copies I know that the
former Scotland art scotland yard art
squad is here so i'm not copies fix but
they're not authentic which is actually
maybe not a too bad thing and and yes
there are things happening around the
world the Security Council resolution
2199 last year these very weak actually
today in the German parliament debate
about the catawba truths Gazette's the
new legislation for protection of
culture property I do strongly believe
that this is the time to break the
momentum in illicit traffic on the
demand side is the moment
to break this demand where where the
people are buying it we don't have so
many possibilities to intervene on the
supply side I think and direct general
from UNESCO has said this many times we
have looting and illicit trafficking
going on on an industrial scale and in
an unprecedented scale and it's really
time not to look at that and watch it
and be not active the other point I
would like to make is that my friend
mamoon up to Kareem said it today there
was another quote I I very much liked
his sentence at the end common heritage
means common responsibility and that
calls us you know at this UN Global
colloquium for university presidents as
universities as as stakeholders to cause
us to really collaborate to increase our
collaboration isn't that impressive
what's definite by a quarry only dead
after the earthquake in bham and I was
there with him in April 2004 and I have
seen that city actually 40,000 people
were killed in this earthquake and they
were living in tents and they say the
argument was not yet world heritage and
sixty percent of them said it's really a
high priority to rebuild and we see that
now on Palmyra that our Syrian
colleagues want to rebuild it hopefully
not too quick and not too fast but they
want to rebuild it and they should do
the same in Aleppo s Gustav are also
saying because we need to connect to the
normal people you need to connect to the
people to make the cultural heritage
preservation and cultural heritage
actually a place for civic civic
engagement as Molly has said and reach
out to to the other players and to the
other parties in that game including the
military yes the police the car industry
those who are not in that room today and
with this I thank you very much for all
of your contributions I especially thank
of course the moderators my dear
colleagues from Yale University in the
morning I cut from cap sees rod
Mackintosh and Alan platters for
stewarding through this day my
colleagues in
the institute for the preservation of
cultural heritage of course who worked
very very hard for this and it's only
the beginning I mean when only the first
day of a week there will be many more
things to come and there will be many
more opportunities to thank and actually
to work as well for my colleagues in
west campus administration in oak park
in the Office of International Affairs
and many many volunteers around campus
helping us to go through and on a
technical point because we have 27 we
have to clear with 430 it is wonderful
thank you moderators for keeping that
join us join us now at the reception in
the yale peabody museum starting at five
thirty you're all invited in what is
called the Sistine Chapel of
paleontology the Great Hall of the yale
peabody museum sorry for the Smithsonian
colleagues I think we have the better
collection because you know where this
collection that the student comes from
right from Yale from Austin marsh so
maybe restitution I don't know I'm
Germans I'm not speaking to this join us
at the reception in the in the VIP room
at five-thirty and of course join us to
listen to culture and Christ is
presented by UNESCO director-general
Irina Bokova at 7pm in the school of
management in the Jung auditorium which
for those who then still can't stand
will be followed by a panel on diversity
in culture has a casual heritage
preservation with many participants many
of you will be speaking again moderated
by Professor Laura veksler and finishing
with a great cultural group here at an
organized by Paul messy actually
colleague of the IPC edge and finishing
with a culture group here at Yale which
is also very interesting and does a
great job in music and singing the
shades so yeah you're in for a long day
join us don't leave us and see you soon
thank you very much
you